so you may remember for loss yeah if you
add up a whole bunch of others if you
had up a whole bunch of numbers like say
for instance 5 Plus 5 Plus 5 Plus 5 okay
rather than writing add five times we
have a bit of shorthand for that if you
add and you repeatedly aller
we call that multiplication yeah so
we've seen this idea before now just
like if you added a dad we have shorter
ways to write that if you multiply and
multiply and multiply we also have
shorthand for that does it know what
that's called anyway yeah yes very good
a power we say that number five is
raised to a power of four in this case
because I multiplied it four times okay
now people should probably recognize
that if I multiply by something not four
times but just just twice that has a
special name if you multiply five times
five just by itself right you could say
five to the power of two but instead we
say five square very good no squared
squared here we say five to the power of
four we just say the whole thing and we
named the number
why does - why is it get a special name
and why this square yeah okay so
squaring is important it's like the you
know after one comes two so that makes
its and if you do it to the power of
three that also has a special name
zealand oh yeah cubes very good but
after that no special names okay what
it's sort of alluding to is what is five
straight by the way what's the actual
number equal to yeah ten no ten would be
then another way moving on I'll show you
let me say that because 10 gets to what
this doesn't this is why I put them
together you add lots of times you will
get ten but if you multiply lots of
times we'll get something else we'll do
try 25 very good okay thanks of
something so glad we mentioned that
high-fives I'm 25 now 25 deported
because if you take a shape
surprise surprise square right and if
its side legs up of five like we're here
it's area will be 25 square units
okay so it's not just the coincidence
like you know whoever was maybe this is
like I like squares squares on my
favorite shape okay no no there's
actually a meaning behind it it's a
square right so this is five squared
right five squared is 25 that's what
leads us into this square roots they
clearly have something to do with
squaring right the idea of the root is
like that's where it comes from like you
know where does a tree come from it
comes from its roots okay so if v square
is 25 therefore the square roots like
it's going backwards right so therefore
and you can write this as well the
square root of 25 is when I come from it
already get to be fire well I came from
five didn't I it's like going backwards
okay in fact that's such an important
that you know we're gonna write that
down
this is squaring okay just just to save
you by the way when you have the square
root the verb for that is not square
rooting not just because it sounds a bit
weird it's taking the square root taking
the square root and like I said it's
literally like don't we backwards where
did you come from
25 where did you come from the answer is
I came from five that's where I came
from
okay now because the square root of 25
is 5 we actually know a whole bunch or
Squared's cuz we know a whole bunch of
squares right so you can put this
underneath I'm just gonna keep on going
to the right but how much space of heat
one squared is of course shout out to me
1 1 times 1 is 1 so therefore the square
root of 1 is 1
ok so 2 squared is 4 so therefore the
square root of 4 is 2
ok good 3 squared is right and so
therefore the square root of 9 is 3
grand